hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the course of
the long argument being made within his
meditations particularly from meditation
3 onward Rene Descartes is introducing
or rather reintroducing since he thinks
we have this idea back in our minds at
all times
the idea of an omnipotent God a God who
lacks no perfections whatsoever a
Supreme Being and in meditation for when
he is concerned with the issue of human
error the thing that motivated the
entire project of the meditations to
begin with he has to take on a bit of
what we call theodicy that is explaining
God's ways literally but another way of
understanding theodicy is getting God
off the hook this is something that has
been done really throughout the ages
many Christian thinkers are doing this
but even pre-christian thinkers as well
in philosophy so dick earth has the
human being and a world that he's slowly
getting us back to and a God who created
the human being and
maintains a human being in existence so
then the question is since I know that I
make mistakes
isn't God responsible for that and so
Descartes considers a number of ways of
attacking this this problem the very
first discussion that he has early on in
the fourth meditation say it says that
God is not a deceiver
now why is God not a deceiver well
because to want to deceive is going to
be involving a lack of perfection or you
could say an imperfection so he says I
recognize that it's impossible that God
would ever deceive me why because in
every fraud and every deception topa
hoih
that there is always some sort of
imperfection and he says it seems that
wanting to you know although it seems
that being able to deceive is a mark of
subtlety or power you know if you think
you might think about the evil genius
that he brought up in meditation too he
says still to want to deceive is
witnesses without any doubt to a kind of
weakness or malice and so weakness would
be a lack of perfection the lack of
strength even if this being is super
powerful would be lacking something
malice is a lack of the perfection of
goodness so God cannot want to deceive
us so does God to see this by mistake
then or you know does this get God off
the hook Descartes then says well we got
to be careful let's think about what
error actually is error he goes on a
little bit later to say is not something
that is real it doesn't have a real
being
it's owned everything that is real you
could say God is on the hook for
everything that has a positive being so
he says I recognize her I know that
error insofar as error is not something
real that depends on God but that it's
only a defect so a little bit later
he'll talk about it as a lack a monk and
mult or more specifically a privation of
a kind of knowledge that ought to be
within us and the word for knowledge
uses their is connect sauce we should
understand that quite broadly to
encompass any sort of knowledge so
there's there's something lacking within
myself and again we could say okay well
that's nice so God didn't create error
itself God's not actively deceiving you
but God created you so isn't he still on
the hook and and we can ask this
question couldn't God have created me in
such a way that I would never actually
go wrong about things and you know the
answer to that is not provided early on
in this meditation number four but
Descartes is gonna get us eventually to
the point where we see that actually we
don't have much to complain about God
created us in such a way that if we want
to avoid error and we want to do the
work that's involved in avoiding error
if we're not so committed to say our pet
ideas and assumptions or you know
jumping into all sorts of judgments that
perhaps we don't have good grounds to
make if we can exercise a little bit of
a Cesis of the will not de cartes term
but but a good term for this a little
disciplining of the will then we can
actually avoid errors and that's what's
being developed in the meditations and
particularly in meditation for so how
would this actually work well you know
the short story of this isn't and we'll
talk about this more elsewhere is that
we should try to suspend
our judgments as much as possible so
that the will doesn't outrun the
intellect or the understanding we ought
to say if I can't really understand it
I shouldn't commit myself to it that's
where we run into most of our problems
isn't it
now Descartes also considers the
different human capacities that God gave
us you could say listen maybe you know
God isn't actively deceiving us and he
gave us the possibility of being able to
not be deceived but that's you know way
off after I do a lot of work why didn't
God give me better capacities to to do
this this process with why do I have to
work so hard at it
and so you know he considers whether we
actually have a grounds for complaint so
he says you know looking at myself
seeing that my errors arise out of two
causes that is the power of knowing
which is in me and the power of electing
or better yet my my free choice moly
Arbeit you know he says that is to say
my understanding and also my will
Volante he says the the understanding by
itself does not you know does not assert
nor does it deny anything but all it
does is conceive ideas of things that
then afterwards I can assert or deny so
the understanding or the intellect or if
you like reason is engaged in this
process of grasping the world that has
ideas that it works with now it's it's
it's actually quite limited as he says
and so this is where we might want to
criticize God right he says there isn't
any reason that could actually prove
that God ought to have given me a
greater and more ample Faculty of
knowing than that which he
and you know if I if I consider it I
don't have to to think that you know it
should have been made perfect or
anything like that it's actually pretty
good
it's just not perfect there's a lot of
things I don't know my acquiring
knowledge of things often asks us happen
in steps that's the kind of
understanding that I have and if I
consider things closely and I take my
own pride or egoism out of it I'll
realize there's a lot of things I don't
know but I could come to know them you
know at least some of them or at least
have some you know good assurances that
things are probably this way we really
have nothing to complain about Descartes
says when it comes to the powers of our
understanding certainly he has nothing
to complain about he's a very bright man
who could you know at a young age solve
all sorts of mathematical problems he
doesn't have much to to gripe about he
also says this about our other mental
faculties memory imagination and then he
says other things we know whatever other
power he says when I examine them I
don't find anything any one of them
which isn't in myself quite small and
limited and in God would be inmense and
infinite but that doesn't mean that I
have a cause to complain about them as a
matter of fact knowing that my
understanding or intellect knowing that
my memory that my imagination are in
fact limited could help me to better use
them because with this all turns on is
something else
our own freewill and here Descartes goes
back and forth between two terms that
some theorists will distinguish leave
our beats right which in Latin is
you know the arbiter 'i'm the judgment
the the decision and Volante will right
now they can both be understood here and
a carts thing as will and as a free will
and part of what makes the will free is
that it can decide itself god has given
us this Faculty of will and we can
decide what to do with it and making the
wrong choice with that that's where we
get ourselves into trouble so he says
the will is is very different he says
there I I experienced in myself the will
to be so great that I cannot conceive at
all of the idea of another will that
would be more ample and more extensive
to lose a Tom view so he says Minoo this
is what makes me know that I I bear
within myself the image and the
resemblance of God our wills are so
unlimited right they exceed any limits
any born in French any borders they
exceed it so much that we are in fact
like God so he says you know the will
consists simply in that we can do
something or not do it that is to say
affirm it or deny it pursue it or flee
it or he says rather in that in order to
affirm or deny to pursue or flee things
that the understanding proposes to us we
act in such a way that we don't feel
ourselves to be constrained by something
else
so our wills are very extensive they
exceed any limit that can be placed upon
them doesn't mean that everything that
we do a lotta matically within the world
that we live in happen the way that we
will it but we can woo it right we can
we'll crazy things we can decide for
ourselves that we ought you know if we
want to you know play around with some
of the ideas that came up early in the
meditations that we want to believe that
we're made of glass or that we want to
consider de cartes meditations that's up
to us and so we don't have anything to
complain about when it comes to the will
either as a matter of fact I suppose you
could say why didn't God create me with
such a will that I would never will the
wrong thing it wouldn't be a will then
it's up to us to will what we choose to
will that's the very nature of a faculty
of will so you know we don't really have
any complaints that we can make any
serious complaints about the human
capacities that God gave us according to
Descartes and he tells us that none of
the capacities that we received from God
are causes of our errors it's rather the
way in which we use them so there's
nothing wrong with the capacities as
such limited or unlimited powerful or
weak
it's rather what we choose to do with it
so it really in some respect does depend
on our will because our will does in
fact get to decide what we're going to
think about and what we're going to will
and all that but it's it's more it you
could say in the use of the will rather
than in the will itself that the problem
arises so insofar as we've been
generated and maintained in existence by
this Supreme Being God is not the cause
of errors according to Descartes we are
the cause of the errors that we saw
her and we are also able in the way that
were made to avoid falling into those
errors
you